زعما اقوى اقتصادين في العالم سيلتقيان
الاسبوع المقبل على هامشي قمه العشرين في
اندونيسيا بايدن واتشي على موعد مع ساعات
من الحوار المعقد ستطرح فيها الكثير من
المشاكل الخلافيه التي احتدمت في الاشهر
الماضيه خاصه بعد زياره نانسي بيلوسي الى
تايوان ومن هذه الجزيره تحديدا سيبدا
الحوار فبكين كشفت عملياتها العسكريه حول
تايوان قبيله اللقاء المرتقب في رساله
باننا لن نتنازل عن مبدا الصين الواحده
وعلى واشنطن الالتزام بذلك في المقابل
يضعوا بايضا مجموعه من الاولويات التي
يريد من الصين التعاون فيها بدءا من
اوكرانيا فواشنطن طالبتين في اكثر من
مناسبه بوقف دعمها لموسكو واتخاذ موقف صار
ضد الحرف اوكرانيا الخطوط الحمراء التي
يضعها كل من الرئيسين يريد توضيحها في
اللقاء مع شيء دون ترك اي مجال للشئ اهميه
وهذا اللقاء تاتي في انها المره الاولى
التي يلتقي فيها بايدن واتشي كرئيسين وجها
لوجه فجولات السابقه من المفاوضات كانت
افتراضيه وتبقى المنافسه الاقتصاديه بما
فيها صناعه الرقائق الالكترونيه من اهم
المسائل العالقه والتي يسعى الرئيسان
لتحقيق المكاسب فيها كل من جانبه وبحسب
مصالح بلاده طبعا
[موسيقى]